details surrounding the new netflix film
anola homes are becoming more clear now
that we have a new teaser and release
date so let's take a look at what we can
expect from that right now on the
ketchup
netflix recently tweeted out the first
teaser trailer for anola homes a new
movie produced by and starring millie
bobby brown as
inola the 14 year old sister of world
famous detective
sherlock holmes you're not alone if you
didn't know he had a sister cause i
didn't
the tweet came complete with a coded
message that one deciphered says that
the movie will be released on september
23rd
on netflix you could also just look at
the new official poster for the release
date but like
what's the fun in that her mind sharp as
a tank and thanks to the teaser along
with some recent first look photos we've
gotten to see some of the film's other
stars like henry cavill
sherlock holmes sam claflin as mycroft
holmes
helena bonham carter as eudorian holmes
plus a deal akhtar and susan wilcoma
now the film was directed by harry
bradbeer who has recently worked on
shows like fleabag and killing eve and
the screenplay was done by jack thorne
known for
certified fresh films like wonder and
the aeronauts
so it begins now anola was actually not
a character in arthur conan doyle's
original classic detective novels but
rather the brainchild of author
nancy springer she wrote the popular six
part anola homes young adult book series
between 2006 and 2010
and based on netflix's synopsis of the
film which reads while searching for her
missing mother intrepid teen anola homes
uses her sleuthing skills to outsmart
big brother sherlock and help a runaway
lord
it appears the film will be based on the
first of those books called the case of
the missing marquess
and similar to past sherlock holmes
adaptations the teaser shows what seems
to be a playful and talented cast in a
fun-filled story not to mention some
fourth wall breaking from anola kind of
like this
tis i we gotta tell you it's worth
noting that the doyle estate is actually
suing netflix along with author nancy
springer her publisher
and legendary pictures the estate is
basically claiming that a nicer more
respectful sherlock holmes violates the
copyright of some of doyle's later work
no word yet on if that will impact the
release of this film but if they want to
do any sequels which why not i mean it
is a six book series the remaining
sherlock copyrights will expire
at the end of 2022 not that millie bobby
brown will be looking for things to do
since she'll keep cashing checks from
netflix
now that we know the upcoming four
season of stranger things will not be
the end
of the series thank you demogorgon gods
[ __ ] all right friends it's time for us
to kick it over to you now are you
excited for anola homes on netflix also
how excited are you
about henry cavill playing sherlock
holmes let us know all your thoughts and
feelings in the comments section and of
course if you want more movie and
streaming news
head on over to runtomatos.com and if
you don't want to miss out on
any future episodes of this show be sure
to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always thank
you so much for watching the ketchup my
name is
perez and i can't wait to see you in the
next video bye
[Music]
you